MARKUS KLUTE: Hello and
welcome back to 8.701.
So in this class we're going to
talk about the range of forces
and specifically how
the range of forces
depends on the mass of
the particle involved
in transmitting the force.
We have seen this table
before, the different forces,
the strong force, the
electromagnetic force,
and the weak force,
and the boson
which carries the force, gluons,
photons, and the W and the Z
bosons.
But now we want to
actually just look
into the aspect of the range
and how masses interplay here.
So you all know the
electromagnetic potential
due to a point charge given
by the Maxwell equation.
We have seen this
equation before
and the time-independent
potential here.
You also know that the
massless photon gives rise
to an infinite range of
electromagnetic [INAUDIBLE]..
But the question now
is, how would this
change, how would
this be modified
if the photon were massive?
But to do this we have to
generalize just a little bit.
First of all, we have to look
at the time-dependent equation
or the wave equation.
And this is wave equation.
You have also seen this before.
Wave equation, and by
adding a mass term.
So we are using here
an equation which
has to be fulfilled
by our particle
simulation between energy,
momentum, and mass.
We have discussed this in the
context of special relativity
before.
What we are trying
to do now is build
a Schrodinger-like
equation by using
the quantum mechanical operators
for energy and momentum.
So we just add
this here and find
a new equation, which is called
the Klein-Gordon equation.
So this equation has to be in
all particle waves or particles
have to fulfill the equation.
So the question is,
what kind of solutions
does this kind of equation have?
How does this look like?
And if now start from, again,
a time-independent equation,
you find solutions
which look like this.
And you see again
very similar, then,
to before the charge
over some constant
as a function of radius, but you
also see this exponential term.
And what we see here
is this potential,
this form of potential is
called Yukawa potential.
And what's nicely
shown in this plot here
is, again, the potential
or the function
of radius in units
of centimeters,
the dependency of
the mass [INAUDIBLE]
the range of the
force and the mass.
So you see here as an example
for the mass equal to here.
Mass is going to 1 GeV and
mass is going to 10 GeV.
And you can easily see
the range of the force
is reduced by the fact that
the particle actually had mass.
Now, the gauge boson, the boson
of the weak interaction, the W
and the Z boson
are quite massive.
They have masses in
the order of 80, 90,
in the order of 100 GeV.
So you can see that
the masses actually
leads to a reduction of
the range of this force.
And yet, we find--
here, just don't look.
Don't look at the
gravitational part here.
It's not part of
the standard model.
If you look at
electromagnetic interaction,
where the range is
infinite, we find
that the range of
the weak interaction
is 10 to the minus 18 meters.
So this is greatly
reduced, because
of the masses of the particles.
If you just look at
the charge itself,
we would find that
the weak interaction
and the electromagnetic
interaction
are actually quite comparable.
We will also talk about
the strong interaction.
We see here there's
a strong interaction
that the coupling, the
alpha, is in the order of 1.
And when we talked
about Feynman diagrams,
we talked about
perturbation theory.
If you do a perturbation theory
for a interaction of order
of 1, couplings of order 1,
your vertices on the order of 1,
you will see that perturbation
theory might break down.
So, OK.
So what we have seen in this
lecture is how a mass, or how
masses, reduce the
range of a force.
We have simply built
Klein-Gordon equation here,
looked at a solution, and found
that there is this diminishing
of the range of the force.
Later, we will look at one
additional complication,
and another equation
which has to do
with [INAUDIBLE]
particles, which
is the so-called
Dirac equation, which
has to be fulfilled or
hold up by the fermions.
But that's beyond the
scope of this class.
We'll look at this
later in more detail.